Brexit! Means that Britain is leaving the EU
Maybe it will happen? Maybe not?
Or the United Kingdom simply splits
Now this is a mess, so let’s talk about it briefly.
First of all: How did it happen?
In the UK, the number of independent party supporters has grown in recent elections.
Because the UK used a "simple majority" voting system that was awful.
Instead of allocating parliamentary seats in proportion to the number of votes from different parties.
The supporters of the Conservative Party are slowly being sucked up by the Independent Party.
So the Conservative Party promised to hold the referendum in the 15-year election.
In order to win the people to vote for themselves
Finally the Conservative Party won. But this election became
The election in the history of Britain that is the least representative of public opinion. (Click on the map to see the details)
And the referendum on the Brexit is still around
Eventually passed 52 to 48 in the case of a high voter turnout rate
So what's next?
Article 50 of the EU Treaty does allow the country to withdraw
Basically an "exit button"
But the Conservative Prime Minister, who promised to press the button at the beginning
But he resigned and ran for the first time. Leading the UK to wait
Although I have discussed it again here.
"This time, it’s really legal to play."
Or re-election
But the new British Prime Minister does not want to do this.
In theory, this time, Congress needs to pass a
"Yes, we really have to quit" law
But they don’t seem to be in a hurry
At the same time, the EU hopes that Britain will leave quickly. But the British plan
First determine the relationship with the EU countries in the future
But as long as the UK does not withdraw, the EU simply does not want to take care of her.
After all, the first negotiation will be beneficial to the UK, and the post-negotiation will benefit the EU.
Plus the EU can't force Britain to quit
This caused a deadlock
Finally, because all parties can't figure it out
The next step will happen, only the day knows
The situation is foggy, so
The following are all guesses!
As a Brexit gambler, I bet a 15% chance that the UK will go abroad as a whole.
That is, the United Kingdom as an independent country has the right to decide on its own trade, immigration, and law.
The United Kingdom has since become a country that is not in the EU. Just like the relationship between Brazil and the EU
If this chance seems too low. Because the new head is relatively reluctant
And most of the public opinion also tends to leave the European Union.
So here are some of my points: first
The Conservatives don’t want Britain to really leave the EU
Although they have voted for the referendum, they are neutral.
May even object privately
Because the Conservative Party prefers to protect the interests of business groups.
And Brexit will cause huge economic turmoil
Especially large economies like banks
On the eve of the 15-year election, the Conservative Party may feel
The people will not be really stupid to agree to Brexit, so they gamble to attack the Independent Party.
But in the end, I played off, 52 to 48.
Even the new prime minister who is firmly supportive of Brexit.
Also opposed to Brexit before taking office. Second point:
Many Brexit propagators are not sincere. I don’t face reality until the results come out.
They are unprepared after leaving the country, as if "we never intended to win"
The party leader of the Independence Party resigned immediately, and it seemed very awkward at this moment of cheering victory.
Then the Conservative Prime Minister resigned, but those who are the most joyous, but no one is willing to come out
Ha ha
Another interesting point is that the referendum itself does not have any legal benefits.
Just a consensus reached by all parties
The vote itself is just a poll, but it is promoted as a referendum.
All of this implies that most people don’t really want to leave the European Union.
Of course, if the government really ignores this vote, although technically feasible
But it will give people a feeling of super undemocrat
However, just as Brexit was promoted to enhance national strength and independence,
The international market and the domestic economy are singing
The distribution of voting areas also indicates that the UK may not be able to leave the EU as a whole.
After the vote was over, Scotland first indicated that it did not support disapproval.
The Scots want and will stay
If the UK retreats as a whole, I bet 97% chance that Scotland will leave the UK and stay in the EU
On top of this, if Scotland is independent, I bet 45% chance that Northern Ireland will also take off from England and unify the island of Ireland.
Be crazy again if Scotland and Northern Ireland are independent
I will even bet 5% chance of London City leaving England
Then join the European Union as an independent city-state. Think about a simple explosion
After all, the city state is so cute.
This leaves only England and Wales to be lily
Of course, neither of them can't go on because there are many similar regimes in the moment.
But the international market has clearly stated that "do not want to" the UK as a whole to leave the EU
So the future seems very dangerous
And the Brexit supporters obviously do not want to end this ending when they vote.
But even if you ignore the possibility of the alliance collapse
On the one hand, it is the majority of people who voted to leave Europe.
On the one hand, entrepreneurs and politicians
Neither of these two aspects really wants to leave the European Union.
This political consideration is also the reason why I give a low probability to Brexit.
So, this is why I think the possibility of 30%, nothing will happen
The British government has been consuming this and pretending to continue to move forward, but in fact nothing is done.
This intricate time will become a new video theme.
“About how the UK spends a hundred years leaving the EU”
It’s as if two countries suddenly found each other in a state of war.
Because there was a xx agreement that forgot to revoke
This kind of ending will not be ideal, because the government, enterprises and people do not like to hang in the air.
But never underestimate the limits of human procrastination
Even Miss Suoh (the Prime Minister) does not want to be in a hurry.
Just got things done.
But I think the last possibility is the biggest.
55% chance that the UK will not leave the country at all
The EU has many intricate classifications for member countries.
Britain can leave the EU
But stay in the European Economic Area. This is also considered to have left the EU.
In fact, the UK had negotiated with the EU before the current bad debt occurred.
Deepen cooperation in the European Economic Area. But this negotiation was put on hold because of the referendum.
But this agreement may still be in a corner now.
But this compromise is actually not good on both sides.
The initial appeal of the Brexit supporters will not be reached.
From immigration, EU membership fees, to EU law, all remain unchanged
The only difference is that the UK must give up all seats in the European Parliament.
So the UK has no say in the EU and still has to follow EU law.
Even EU supporters will not like this ending.
But no matter what, I think the possibility is the most likely
Because of this, the economic market will remain stable and satisfy entrepreneurs.
And politicians can also minimize losses and maintain national unity.
Establish an image of "obeying public opinion"
Certainly no one wants to be prime minister when the country collapses?
All in all: all the above endings are not perfect
The overall Brexit is basically the end of the UK
And it also violates the principle of economic self-interest. Who knows?
But if you don’t do it, you will violate the principle of democracy.
The UK is currently at a multi-directional intersection that determines the future
Maybe the EU will suddenly collapse because of various problems.
And the England-Wales Union is reborn in the ashes
Maybe Britain is the biggest loser. Or nothing will change
Where is the road, and what is the future? No way to know
Britain can only stand in the fog, blindly choose a road
Good luck, Britain, no matter what you choose
This video is part of the sponsorship of Squarespace
You want to create a website to explain in detail the British government
What do you need to do and why? Squarespace is where you are going
Nothing is faster and easier than building a website.
You don't need to understand complex HTML code
You only need to use their drag and drop tools to generate code.
This is where I run my website, I am their fan
He removed the complicated part of building the website and left you with interesting parts.
You get a 10% discount when you visit squarespace.com
It’s best to let them know that you’ve been from this channel.
Bet, ladies and gentlemen. Bet it